and here's the solution you create a new
layout resource file call it list item
forecast and the root element is a
textview and you just hit OK now that we
have the item created we can switch to
the text pane here's the solution code
we have a single text view where the
width is match parent and the height is
wrapped content we also give it a
minimum height so the item is capable we
use the framework preferred item height
for this since there'll be more vertical
space now with a minimum height we
specify gravity so that the text inside
the text view will be centered
vertically
lastly we specify ID which we gave you
earlier great now we have a list item